[Musique]
il dit l'agente américaine devrait donc
y drogue atterrissez immédiatement vague
féculent
je m'appelle barry s'il tient pour les
dégâts et pour ta soeur salut ma puce
et pourtant vélo est ce que tout ça
c'est du vécu
vous m'avez jamais vu major de promo à
la patrouille civile
vous méritez mieux que de piloter des
bus bienvenue à miami bienvenue à
bakersfield
vous n'avez jamais eu envie de plus
baril vous devriez servir votre pays
vous êtes assez bien
on a des livraisons à vous confier
c'est les gars tout ça tant que vous le
faites pour les gentils
là où
barry seal c'est un [ __ ] de génie des
pilotes de ligne paris c'est comme ça
que tu nourris cette famille ça va être
bien pour nous dire c'est légal tu me
fais confiance
on élargit notre champ d'action baril
[Musique]
oui non
roscoe a déterré soeur milieu du jardin
ya des billets éparpillés un peu partout
je ramasserait demain matin blanchiment
d'argent
vous saviez vous que les plus grands
coffres cse des cadillac
j'en offre une à chacun de vous pour
récompenser vos efforts ils vont me
relâcher et vous aurez beau faire ça n'y
changera rien il peut partir dans leurs
attendus
vous auriez dû prendre le cadillac
[Musique]
je bossais pour la cia pour la dea et
pour pablo escobar milk unienne temps ce
qu'ils ont ça fait 1500 quillan en une
livraison tous les livres et tous ferme
ta gueule
[Musique]